ein coworking space in warschau seit
stunden angespanntes warten auf die
entscheidende nachricht
keine cover maria b elf jahre gefängnis
maxim snack zehn jahre gefängnis die
beiden bleiben in haft innerhalb von
zehn tagen kann man gegen das urteil in
berufung gehen nationalcoach befürchtung
ist eingetreten elf jahre gefängnis für
ihre schwester maria callas nick cover
begründung versuchte illegale
machtergreifung maria hat es gewagt bei
der letzten präsidentschaftswahl
diktator alexander lukaschenko
herauszufordern das urteil ist hart
ich hatte natürlich eine klitzekleine
hoffnung gehabt aber keine illusionen
es ist trotzdem sehr schwer sich dieses
urteil überhaupt zu verinnerlichen
[Musik]
ich heiße danach comic meine schwester
maria callas mika ist schon seit mehr
als 300 tage hinter gitter katzian das
größte sorge ist dass maria im gefängnis
etwas zustößt
medienpräsenz könnte ihr leben retten
darum schickt asiana videobotschaften um
die welt hat ihren job gekündigt um für
die schwester zu kämpfen geht
demonstrieren zur not allein tatjana
selbst ist nach warschau geflogen und
bei jeder solidaritätsveranstaltung für
die belarussische opposition dabei sie
erzählt immer wieder wie maria und ihre
mitstreiterinnen bei der wahl 2020 gegen
lukaschenko kämpften zwei sind jetzt im
exil maria callas nica blieb und wurde
vom regime erst entführt und jetzt
verurteilt
der wichtigste feind unseres sieges ist
nicht das regime der wichtigste feind
des sieges ist unsere angst habt keine
angst
und nun kann meine schwester in einer
strafzölle landen nur weil sie mit einem
anderen häftling spricht deswegen
kommunizieren die gefangenen mit anderen
mitteln durch klopfen an die wand an
gitter oder heizkörper so sagt man hallo
danke oder gute nacht seit der
verhaftung ihrer schwester reis tatjana
quer durch europa besonders oft ist sie
in deutschland denn deutschland
engagiert sich sehr für die politischen
gefangenen in belarus
659 inhaftierte sind es derzeit
viele gefangene haben chronische
erkrankungen es gibt menschen die im
knast krank werden weil sie dort
monatelang bleiben wir bitten
internationale organisationen um hilfe
sie sollten druck auf die belarussische
regierung ausüben damit diesen
gefangenen geholfen wurde der einladung
ins theaterhaus stuttgart im juli ist
tatjana besonders gern gefolgt denn ihre
schwester ist eigentlich musikerin hat
querflöte und dirigieren studiert
maria callas nie cover selbst hat das
kammermusik trio vis á vis mitgegründet
und das widmet ihr nun ein ganzes
konzert
also als alles geschah wo sie in
gefangenschaft
gehalten ist was mir alles total absurd
und surreal
also es macht immer noch keinen sinn für
mich jetzt immer noch nicht gesehen
seitdem also es war alles nur im
fernsehen und über erzählungen also es
ist nicht zu fassen für mich hallo hallo
hallo meine liebe so oft es geht
telefoniert hat jana mit ihrem vater der
in ihrer heimatstadt minz geblieben ist
im gefängnis durfte er maria nicht
besuchen erst jetzt im gerichtssaal
konnte er sie zumindest von weitem sehen
hier in belarus ist die unterstützung
von außen ganz wichtig für mich und
andere eltern deren kinder völlig
grundlos und ungerecht im gefängnis
gelandet sind wir wissen nicht was tun
und wie wir ihnen helfen können
von warschau aus schreibt hat es ja nach
rometsch auf briefe an ihre schwester
nur einen bruchteil der nachrichten an
und von maria lassen die belarussischen
behörden überhaupt durch und wenn dann
zensiert trotzdem briefe helfen gegen
das gefühl der machtlosigkeit immer mehr
menschen in belarus schreiben mit
briefen an politische gefangene gegen
das regime an
millionen von menschen machen sich
sorgen um die politischen gefangenen
ganz viele menschen und familien wurden
betroffen
seien politische gefangene zu schreiben
daraus ist eine die ganze massenbewegung
entstanden viele menschen schreiben
jeden tag an maria die meisten briefe
bekommt sie natürlich nicht aber die
menschen machen trotzdem weiter dass es
inzwischen ihr hobby am wochenende
schreiben sie einige dutzend gefangene
an sogar zusammen mit anderen leuten
razzia nach rom iec will weiter für ihre
schwester maria kämpfen sie weiß solange
der diktator lukaschenko an der macht
ist kann sie wohl nicht zurück nach
hause und ihrer schwester maria nicht in
freiheit leben doch sie hofft dass das
regime den kürzeren zieht vor dem ende
von maria callas nica was elf langen
jahren haft